the david pakman show is of course made
possible by viewers like you through our
membership program listeners like you
you can sign up at
joinpackman.com it's quick it's easy
if you already have a membership you can
also now gift memberships by checking
the box that says
this is a gift funny enough
as you sign up and then we will give
your gift subscription to someone on our
waiting list currently
600 people waiting for membership so
it's a beautiful number
let's hear from some people in the
audience we do these calls now via
discord you can find our discord at
davidpakman.com
discord
why don't we start today
um this is interesting let's start with
aaliyah from the faroe islands we've
never had a pharaoh islands caller
before aaliyah
you're on the air what's going on
no boy
aaliyah don't let us down
aaliyah from the pharaoh islands please
unmute and we'll be able to chat
well that's a shame that would have been
interesting let's go instead to brian
from phoenix brian from phoenix you're
on the air
hi david hey how are you
i am doing amazing uh i wanted to first
appreciate you flouting the pushback and
uh sticking with the an historic
pronunciation
i think it's um oh boy i appreciate
you're going going your own way on that
all right fair
um
i'm wondering if you believe uh in the
long term it would be a
uh
more beneficial
more progressive outcome to remove the
filibuster altogether
and uh sort of have the senate answer to
the voters for whatever legislation is
able to be passed in a in a 50 50 senate
or if you think that that would lead us
in the opposite direction in a in a less
progressive direction good question so
i here's my view on this
if i don't think about this
strategically
the filibuster doesn't make a lot of
sense to me the filibuster fundamentally
seems anti-democratic so if there were
no political considerations i would say
let's get rid of the filibuster
altogether
in practical terms i'm aware that if
democrats completely nuke the filibuster
at some point it'll come back to haunt
democrats and part of the reason why
is that the senate is fundamentally
anti-democratic and what i mean by that
is we have a hundred senators no matter
how many people live in any particular
state that's the state has two senators
and so there are senators that represent
millions and millions and millions of
people and their senators that represent
i mean i don't know what the wyoming
population is now i think it's like 700
000. so like each wyoming senator in a
sense represents 350 000 people which
gives disproportionate power
to
low population states which are
typically conservative so
i i don't love the filibuster i think it
doesn't make sense and i would be fine
getting rid of it if
we were to somehow fix the
anti-democratic nature of the senate
which doesn't seem like it's going to
happen anytime soon because that's the
way the system works
one semi-follow-up question very quick
would you support adding states for that
in the form of like splitting california
or i'm adding puerto rico i am open to
adding states but it would not be
specifically for that reason i think
that sometimes it would make sense that
there's a lot of pro i mean i think
puerto rico should be a state if it
wants to be um i think there are a
number of different arguments for
splitting up california but for me it's
more about does it make sense for for
economic reasons does it make sense for
other reasons not just as a political
strategy although as a political
strategy it would almost certainly help
democrats
awesome thanks david my pleasure uh
that's a that's a meaty phone call i
like it